The late 60s brought us a revelation, one that should have been obvious all along.
Psychologists John Darley and Bib Latane locked people in rooms,
staged emergencies, and watched something strange unfold.
The more witnesses there were, the less anyone moved.
A woman collapsed.
Screams went up.
And yet no one called for help.
Not because they were cruel.
Because the responsibility had been divided into so many pieces,
each person thought someone else would handle it.
Diffusion of responsibility.
A beautiful thing if you're aiming for solitude.
Now, let's talk about real isolation.
Not the kind you get by fleeing to a cabin in the woods, though.
Honestly, that's just a Romantics fantasy.
True isolation isn't about distance.
It's about presence.
It's about standing in the middle of a crowded room and making sure no one ever touches you.
The Sentinelize Maneuver.
A technique borrowed from the tribes of North Sentinel Island,
who've spent millennia perfecting the art of being left alone.
You see, isolation isn't passive.
It's a strategy.
The world is full of nudges, social media pings, forced team-building exercises,
the relentless optimism of people who actually enjoy other humans.
To stay untouched, you have to fight back.
You have to turn the city into an island.
First, there's the digital trench.
Your phone isn't just a tool, it's a shield.
In any public space, keep the scream between you and the world.
A flickering glow.
A distracted stare.
It's a signal.
Do not approach.
The bystander effect works in reverse.
No one will help you.
And more importantly, no one will bother you.
Then, there's the I'm fine glaze.
A neutral tone.
A room temperature reply.
If someone asks how you are, you don't expand.
You don't invite them in.
Details are hooks.
Conversations are traps.
Stay frictionless.
Next, the diffusion of plans.
When invited somewhere, give the vague affirmative.
That sounds interesting.
I'll let you know.
Then, don't.
Leave them hanging.
A little anxiety.
A hint of unreliability.
Soon, your name carries a weight stress.
Inconvenience.
The faint scent of a bad investment.
And if someone still dares to breach your defenses.
Garnish the interaction with the heavy sigh.
The door slam.
The unspoken, you're wasting my time.
Make it clear you are not here to be engaged.
Now consider the public diner.
A master class in the Sentinelese Maneuver.
A book.
A neutral gaze.
A single person in a crowded bistro, untouchable.
The others see you.
They acknowledge you.
But they don't reach out.
Because you've made it impossible.
And that's the goal.
Alone, together.
Physically present, psychologically untouchable.
The ultimate social achievement being invisible.
In plain sight.
A wall of stone can be climbed.
A wall of indifference.
That's the only one that lasts.